let's say I have some random variable X
and it is a continuous it is a
continuous random random variable and I
want to explore its probability
distribution in fact I want to construct
a probability distribution for it so
let's draw here on the vertical or on
the horizontal axis I should say these
are the values that X can take on and in
the vertical axis I'll essentially say
the probability density for each of
those values and we'll see we'll
discover in a few moments why we are
calling it density so let's say that my
random variable X it can never take on
negative values so it's a zero
probability density of taking on any
value that is negative and then it has a
uniform density of taking on any value
between 0 & 5 so let's say that that's 0
say this is 1 2 3 4 5 and then it can't
take on any value above 5 so it's not
going to as a zero probability of any
value any value greater than 5 0
probability of any value less than 0 and
uniform probability between 0 & 5 so
this is a shaded encircle uniform
probability between 0 0 & 5 so this
right over here when we're talking about
a continuous probability distribution
this can also be referred to as a
probability density function probability
density function sometimes a PDF
probability density function in this
case you might notice it is a uniform it
is a uniform probability density
function now the first question I have
for you is what is the height or what is
this level we see it's uniform but
uniform at what level what is this value
going to be where this horizontal line
intersects the vertical axis for our
probability density function well to
think about it we just have to realize
that whether we're talking about a
continuous random variable or a discrete
random variable the sum the probability
that you get any one
of the possible outcomes the sum of all
of those have to be equal to one you
have a hundred percent chance of getting
one of the possible outcomes for your
random variable whether it's discrete or
continuous
so the sum in the case of a discrete we
kind of summed up the bars in a
continuous random variable we have to
realize it can take on any value not
just one or two or three it could take
on it could take on 3.14159 keeps going
on and on and on forever it could take
on the value of pi' it could take on it
could take on the value of two point
seven one gone and on and on the value
the number e it could take on square
root of two and any number in between so
when we're thinking about all of the
possible scenarios all of the possible
values that our random variable can take
on times the density the probability
actually is now the area the combined
probability of all of the possibilities
are now is now this area so for this
random variable in order for this to be
a legitimate probability density
function or probability distribution the
area here that I've highlighted in
orange this area here needs to be equal
to one so this area needs to be equal to
one and given that this base here is of
length five what does this height need
to be well five times what is going to
be equal to one five times its
reciprocal so we have a uniform density
right here at 1/5 so given that we've
defined this probability density
function in this way let's think about
some probabilities so what if I were to
ask you what if I were to ask you the
probability the probability that X is
greater than one let's say greater than
or equal to 1 and less than or equal to
2 what is this probability going to be
equal to well you just have to say well
what are all the possible values that X
can take on so it can be between 1 and 2
including 1 and 2 and so here is its
combined probability that X is in that
range it's going to be the area under
the curve under the curve under the
under the curve in that range and so
what is this area well the base here
is one the height here is 1/5 we haven't
drawn the height to scale here base here
is one height is 1/5 so it's going to be
1 times 1/5 which is equal to 1/5 let's
think about another one let's think
about another one what is the
probability that our random variable is
greater than or equal to 4 and less
Center equal to 4 and 1/3 what's that
probability going to be equal to so once
again what's the range we can be greater
than or equal to 4 greater than equal to
4 and lepton less than or equal to 4 and
1/3 which is right about there so we
really care about is the area under the
curve under the curve in this range and
lucky for us this is a rectangle so the
base between 4 & 4 & 1/3 you have a
distance of 1/3 and then the height once
again is 1/5 times 1/5 is equal to 1
over 15 now let's do something
interesting now let's do something
interesting what is the probability and
not that the other stuff wasn't that
interesting but let's do something even
more interesting what is the probability
what is the probability that X X is
greater than or equal to 3.9 and less
than or equal to actually let me do it
this way 2.9 let's say X is greater than
or equal to 2.9 or 2 point 9 is less
than or equal to our random variable
which is less than or equal to 3 point 1
that didn't look like an X and is less
than or equal to 3 point 1 what is this
probability going to be equal to so we
have this little range here right over
here the height is 1/5 we've seen that
over and over again but what's the area
of this rectangle well the base here is
between 2 point 9 and 3 point 1 so that
is point zero 2 let me draw that
rectangle a little wider so if we dot
like this draw it zoom in a little bit
this point right over here is 2.9 at
this point right over here is 3 point 1
the difference between the two is 0.2 or
you could say it's 1/5 so 0.2 and then
the height here is 1/5
so the base is 0.2 or 1/5 and then the
height is 1/5 so it's 1/5 times 1/5 is
equal to 1 over 25 well you say well how
is that any more interesting what we
just did well let's escalate a little
bit what's the probability not of that
range let's take the probability let's
take the probability that 2.99
is less than our random variable which
is less than the less than or equal to
two point nine nine is less than or
equal to our random variable which is
less than or equal to three point zero
zero one what is this going to be equal
to so now we've made our range a little
bit smaller our base now is now going to
be point zero two the difference between
three point zero one and two point nine
nine is point zero two so it's now point
zero to base and the same height 1/5 so
the base is now one not one-fifth but
one 50th that's the same thing as point
zero two and we multiply that times 1/5
times 1/5 gives us one let me scroll
over to the right a little bit 1 over
250 and we could keep going we could
keep going and I think you see why this
is getting interesting what's the
probability that two point nine nine
nine is less than or equal to our random
variable which is less than or equal to
three point zero zero one what's this
going to be equal to well same exact
logic the range the base this will range
right of our random variable it is now a
range of one five hundred point zero
zero two one five hundred so it's now
going to be one over five hundred one
over five hundred times the height times
1/5 1/5 which now gives us one 2,500 one
2,500 so you see we're getting closer
and closer to X being exactly three and
our probabilities getting lower and
lower and lower as we narrow our range
we can start getting really really
really close to 3 so with that let's
just finish this video with a very
philosophically interesting question
what is the probability that my
continuous random variable defined this
way what is the probability that it is a
exactly exactly equal to three not three
point zero one not two point nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine what is
the probability that is exactly equal to
three well now our rectangle has
essentially degenerated or it's just
degraded down to just a vertical line
its height is still one fifth but it has
absolutely no width it has absolutely no
width it is a R it is an infinitely
skinny rectangle and so your probability
here it has no area it has no area so
the probability is zero so you actually
have a zero probability of getting
exactly three not two point nine nine
nine not not between two point nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine and three point
zero zero zero one we're talk about
infinite precision getting exactly three
the probability is zero and hopefully
this little progression that we saw
gives you an indication of why that is
is we get to a tighter and tighter range
around three the probability was getting
closer and closer to zero